Michael Hauge: Desire just means there is
something that the character wants.
It isn’t necessarily confined to sexual
or romantic desire.
That just happens to be one of those movies
there was just this elicit sexual…I don’t
know if it was really elicit in 9 and 1/2
weeks or how you’d categorize it…on a
visible level the desire could be to win a
competition.
In fact if you look at Hollywood movies probably
90 percent of Hollywood movies are about characters
who want to one of basically three or four
things.
That is, they either want to win a competition
or win the love of another character.
So that encompasses all sports movies and
all romantic comedies and love stories or
romantic hyphenate movies or they want to
stop something bad from happening.
That is all horror movies, most science fiction
movies, all thrillers, all murder mysteries.
Although Hollywood really doesn’t do murder-mysteries
much, but that’s about stopping a killer
from getting away with the murder.
They want to escape from a bad situation,
like GREAT ESCAPE or PANIC ROOM or HUNT FOR
THE WILDERPEOPLE or they want to retrieve
something.
They want to get something of value and own
it, possess it at the end of the story.
So that is all heist movies, it’s kidnapping
stories rescue stories, we’ve got to go
get this person and get them to safety.
And if you look at the top box office movies
for any top given year, I bet probably 90
out of a 100 are going to fall into one of
those four categories of goal.
Film Courage: So desire doesn’t necessary
mean romantic interest.
It can mean conquering…in the case of the
Helen Mirren movie you mentioned earlier [EYE
IN THE SKY] wanting to find the bad guy, that
conquer is the desire that moves it through,
but conflict is trying to find these bad guys
who have moved throughout the area.
Michael Hauge: Yeah.
That is part of the conflict.
Her goal…that’s a stop movie.
She wants to stop the bad guys from leaving
the house…because it is discovered that
they are bad guys or they are arming some
bad guy.
So they are going to go into some populace
place and hurt a lot of people and she wants
to stop them.
Part of the conflict is they are going to
find them, they have to make sure it’s them,
they’ve got to get the drone in position.
But part of the conflict is what happens when
an innocent bystander comes into the place
where the collateral damage is going to be
done, if there is an innocent person there,
it starts a moral dilemma of is one person’s
life worth risking lives of one hundred to
save?
So then there becomes this moral conflict,
too.
They are all obstacles to her doing what she
wants, which is to stop the bad guys.
Question for the Viewers: Which of these categories
does your movie fall into?